allez après ce petit souci technique on
est de retour avec alain fontaine
président de l'association française des
maîtres restaurateurs le principal vous
êtes dans le tour à la fontaine merci
d'être resté
vous disiez instant que la profession
avait particulièrement été et dépendance
est cette grave crise sanitaire je
voulais avoir votre avis justement sur
la fin du du quoi qu'il en coûte annoncé
par bruno lemerle à cette semaine donc
synonyme de la fin des aides est ce que
le le timing justement est bon
alors il a bien précisé il a bien
précisé que le quoi qu'il en coûte
c'était du macro économiques mais
qu'après il y aurait une vision il y
aura une une posture sous du sur mesure
sert que chaque activité serait bien
analyser et en particulier celle de la
restauration donc les syndicats ont
rendez vous lundi avec bruno le maire
afin d'étudier effectivement ce qui se
passe dans la restauration car six
tasses dans la restauration peut être
dramatique pour certains d'entre nous le
mur de tête est enclin de s'avancer les
remboursements du pg mais aussi les
remboursements de cotisation employés
que l'on doit donc beaucoup sont
beaucoup sont dans la détresse nous on
est en train de faire un sondage chez
les métros instaura teurs qui va sortir
vendredi on a un commentaire libre et on
a beaucoup de désespérance dans ses
commentaires ça veut dire que malgré une
bonne saison en province avec un
tassement de la croissance au moment du
au moment de la mise en place du pass
sanitaires et bien malgré cette saison
il ya des inquiétudes très fort tant
quant à paris et d'autres villes ces
sinistrés donc si vous voulez la rentrée
n'est absolument pas sereine avec un
tourisme familial et de travail dont on
ne sait pas ce qu'il va devenir on ne
sait pas ce que les touristes vont faire
s'ils vont revenir en masse il faut
savoir que l'écologie ceux ci demandent
aux touristes un tourisme plus preuve ça
veut dire moins de voyages en avion ça
veut dire que on va devoir retravailler
sur un tourisme continental et européens
tout ça va devoir être étudié la vente
hors portée qui paie qui est pérennisé
pour certains établissements l'état
kitchen mais également les visions
conférence qui vont faire que les repas
d'affaires
vont être divisés vraisemblement parle
d'eux donc on a une situation de
restauration qui est extrêmement
compliqué à la rentrée avec une
restauration qui va se modifier dans les
années à venir avec des modèles
économiques qu'on va réétudier donc non
c'est pas serein et oui il va falloir
déjà je pense que monsieur le maire et
monsieur plaisait en sont conscients il
va encore falloir aider quelques mois
pour éviter la casse pour éviter des des
lieux de vie des lieux d'art de vivre
des lieux de vivre ensemble qui
fermerait au profit des soit 208 zurich
ou de fast food et c'est vraiment pas la
même chose donc attention à nos
établissements attention à notre art de
vivre est très rapidement avant de se
quitter alain fontaine il nous reste
vraiment quelques secondes alors très
rapidement vous parliez
d'un système économique que l'on devra
modifier dans les années à venir ou ou
peut-être la façon de faire les choses
que l'on va devoir modifier à quoi vous
pensez très rapidement
je pense qu'il va falloir faire en sorte
de ne pas fermer nos restaurants et
d'attirer de plus en plus de clients
dans nos restaurants un repas sur cet
epr est en france on reste en un sur
sept c'est un surdose états unis c'est à
dire que les consommateurs le potentiel
de consommateurs et là il faut les
attirer vers nos restaurants il ne faut
pas qu'il est chez eux devant leur
ordinateur et devant leur télévision
trop longtemps il faut qu'ils viennent
manger je rappelle un repas sur sept est
pris au restaurant ça veut dire que si
repas est pris chez eux contre un repas
sur nos états unis où un repas sur
quatre en espagne donc il faut que nous
nous faisions des efforts très
particulier pour faire revenir les gens
au restaurant il faut trouver des idées
des idées sur les prix des idées sur
deux à des produits de qualité de
proximité faire ce que nous faisons chez
les maîtres restaurateurs travaillant
avec nos producteurs travaillons avec la
culture française et faisons que nos
consommateurs aient confiance en nous
c'est ça l'important voilà un monde donc
qui va sans doute changer merci beaucoup
alain fontaine d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin rappelle que vous êtes président
de l'association française des maîtres
de des maîtres restaurateurs merci
beaucoup